let's talk about the real reason why you
should be drinking lemon water every
single day
the average person does not know the
true
benefits okay with an s of drinking
lemon water because it's actually quite
amazing so let's cover all of the key
points number one by drinking lemon
water on a regular basis
you have the potential to reduce a fatty
liver now this is the phytonutrients in
the lemon water that have the ability to
greatly improve
something called hepatic steatosis now
what does hepatic mean liver what does
steatosis mean that means the
infiltration of fat
into the liver so hepatic steatosis
means a fatty liver
lemon water has the ability to dissolve
the fat in the liver there's other
things as well like purify bile salts
choline
a low-fat diet as in ketogenic diet can
reduce up to 50 of the fat
in your liver within 14 days but if you
add a little lemon to your water you can
actually speed things up all right
number two it can help reduce
cholesterol not that cholesterol is a
bad thing but let's say your liver is
sluggish and your gallbladder's sluggish
and you're not producing enough bio and
that's kind of backing up in the system
lemon water can help increase the flow
of bile through the bile ducts and help
remove some of the excess cholesterol
that's kind of backing up in the system
all right number three
weight loss now lemon water does not
directly help you
lose weight
it can indirectly help you lose weight
now quite a few studies on animals have
shown this but i want to help you
understand the mechanism certain
phytonutrients in lemon water
stimulate
significantly lower blood sugars
they reduce
insulin
resistance
so they lower insulin and that is the
reason why someone can lose weight in
fact if you really want to know how to
lose weight what i would do is not try
to
research how to lose weight i would
research on how to lower
insulin because anything that lowers
insulin is going to help you lose weight
in fact the fat cells cannot shrink it's
impossible for a fat cell to shrink
without lowering insulin despite your
calories all right number four
lemon has an anti-aging effect now yes
the studies were done in animals
but most studies do start in animals and
then you progress to humans but in the
five-week study they lived it on average
three weeks longer now you might be
saying well that's not a long time
but that's only five weeks think about
if you started drinking lemon water on a
regular basis for the rest of your life
it could add up and they also found that
lemon water extended the life of the
microbiome your friendly bacteria which
is pretty interesting all right number
five anti-cancer effects now i'm not
telling you that lemon water is going to
cure your cancer i'm not saying that but
it's something you can add to help
inhibit
cancer in test tube studies it was found
that
certain phytonutrients in lemon water
were able to kill malignant cancer of
the tongue
of the lung
and the colon all right number six and
this is an important one
the reduction of kidney stones
citrate in lemon juice binds with this
thing called oxalate now the most common
type of kidney stone
are oxalate stones calcium oxalate
stones and so if you have citrate in
your body it can bind with the oxalates
to prevent the stone from occurring and
so people that have a tendency to have
kidney stones
are usually low in citrates and if
you're prone to kidney stones
i would recommend
increasing the amount of lemon juice to
roughly about a half of a cup to a cup
of lemon juice every single day now
number seven
it can potentially give you vitamin c
but only if it's from actual lemons that
have not been heated like in your lemon
juice that you would get in a bottle so
when you buy lemon juice at the store it
normally comes pasteurized and the
problem with vitamin c is that it's
sensitive to heat it gets degraded and
destroyed with heat
so when you get bottled lemon juice
you're really getting
next to zero vitamin c but if you get
your vitamin c from an actual lemon
let's say you just take a lemon and you
squeeze it into water one lemon can
provide up to half of your daily
recommended vitamin c or should i say
like almost half so it gives you about
31 milligrams when you need like 70 to
75 per day and vitamin c is so good for
the immune system it's good to prevent
bleeding gums it's good to prevent
spider veins it helps form collagen
it helps keep your arteries from
becoming damaged and many other things
okay the last benefit of lemon water is
in its phytonutrients and there's quite
a few and in these three phytonutrients
there's benefit in improving hemorrhoids
leg sores circulation
spider veins and varicose veins in fact
one of the phytonutrients narenjian is
being tested as a potential treatment
for alzheimer's disease it's also very
antibacterial it has antiviral
properties as well as anti-fungal
properties
so start putting lemon in your water on
a regular basis
definitely add it with the apple cider
vinegar in your water i would recommend
the amount of lemon juice from the whole
lemon or just a couple teaspoons but be
consistent and include it in part of
your liquids on a regular basis now if
you haven't seen my video on apple cider
vinegar
that's the next one you should watch
check it out right here
you